how many people were here in 2007
one two
all right so look at that
that was probably everybody then
i think there were 12 people
it was
it was great right in the church here
yeah
uh it was very exciting and uh it
thrilled me a lot to talk about closure
to that group and uh
and again to talk to lisberries how many
people are those persons
okay good i'm presuming
um everybody knows this period and if
you don't you just gotta struggle along
although there's nothing here
particularly that must be but
um it's a great heritage and uh
certainly closure in the atomic follow
through with that so what i'd like to do
tonight
is talk about the atomic from the
perspective of
it being a functional database it's a
lot of other things as well but that's
an interesting way to think about it
especially for programmers and list
programmers it's an interesting way to
think about it
i do know
and see that there are some people here
who've seen this talk or at least a lot
of the slides from this talk before so
i'm hoping to go through it quickly
enough that a i can get some hands-on
time and b we can get some questions
that everybody at the different levels
can catch up and have something
useful
so
what is atomic it's a new database it's
actually not that new anymore it changes
slides
but uh
where is it from
it's almost three years out now it'll be
three years in the spring
and and i think the value propositions
are or whatever the key points here are
that it it's uh it's trying to be a
database about information management as
opposed to a place to stick your stuff
so information versus place
it's trying to give
the programmer the database as a value
just like any other value they're used
to manipulating like collections or
strings or numbers you have a database
and you can treat that
and program with functions against that
the way you do any other values so it's
very much about what you bring all the
way to the application program
and the third point is also in that same
category
databases traditionally have had a bunch
of cool declarative programming um
things like core engines and sql and
things like that no matter what you
think of sql
it's still great to have that you know
sort of set
algebra which again is something we
usually think of as being over there
it's in some remote thing and it's a
different language and i send it strings
and it's not only for some something i'm
going to have in my own program
but i think that's sort of a shame
because there's a lot of power to
declarative programming and we don't get
to use it that much
and the ultimate objective of all this
stuff
is to make uh programming less complex
so
we're going to talk about that value
proposition a little bit about the
information model
architecture and then
and not too much about architecture
tonight and i'll do a little hands-on
hopefully qa so we'll simplify the value
proposition it's a functional database
all these things would fall out of that
um
right if it's really functional it's not
going to be about places
um
maybe the declarativeness doesn't fall
out of that
so
why do we do functional programming
right it's to stop us from accidentally
doing io
so
it's interesting i i i'm trying to
put good words to this but i do have
this idea that um your programs are
have two essential natures one part of
your program is going to be about moving
stuff around and be sort of machine-like
in that way and the rest of your program
should be logic driven
and unfortunately a lot of the languages
we've had especially in languages like
java
we're actually designed to do the
machinery part and because and that's
all you've got you apply it to
everything it's really a terrible fit
for
um
for doing logic
so we talk about high-level languages we
you know essentially
you're a high level language to the
extent you're not talking about you know
computer do this computer do that right
and and i think we have this problem
especially because your computers used
to be small we used to have to like do a
lot of work to get anything happening on
them not much memory not much power
our program and the machine were
intimate you know when we programmed in
c
you know we didn't really think that our
program was something different from the
machine it was just a way to instruct
the machine we want to get away from
that
and object-oriented programming you know
objects are like little machines
and we use functional programming to
break out of that to get something
that's more like mathematics right it's
pure functions are timeless they don't
have any notion of state
right and it helps you understand what
your program's about that's why we do it
and then hopefully your program is more
likely to do what you want
so
when you adopt functional programming
the problem you have is
generally programs are not just running
in memory one time to produce one answer
they run over time
and they run a different box there's
many boxes all right what's in the
middle of all that usually
this big global variable called the
database
and it ruins everything
so how do we uh
how do we get away from that and the
first thing is really to say
that that i think
the database has to be represented as a
value to a program
um
and that means that
uh of course there there is something
that's changing over time right people
are interacting with it and they're
putting novelty in somewhere right so
there is some place there is some
machine-like thing out there
but we need to reduce the amount of time
we're interacting with the machine and
get back in our own hands
something we can use to do logic with
so what we want to end up with and what
it what i mean to have a database as a
value means that you can write
functions to take database values as
arguments because you can pass a
database to a function
and similarly you can write a function
that returns a database value as its
result
and at that point
uh if you have pure functions and and
you can use databases as arguments or
term values like this you can do
functional programming with the database
and then you have to have all the
regular database stuff
right you want a database to be durable
at least in the case of the atomic we
think it's important for it to be
consistent um a database really is a
database that you sent it gives you
leverage
right if you put a bunch of stuff in a
bag
you know is that a database
well i mean it's a place where all your
stuff is right but if you have to go
you know define everything anytime it's
like
well it's like hadoop
and that's not leverage right if you
have to examine everything to do
anything
then you don't have leverage and so
traditionally you know we have file
systems project databases
uh but we didn't call them databases
until we had more and that more is
usually taking the form of indexes right
something that gives you leverage lets
you get to a particular thing without
examining everything lets you slice and
dice the set a subset of your data so
that you uh
get more power
we still didn't really call them
databases because it wasn't arbitrary it
was sort of like a special purpose
um
and of course you need to share this
across processes and this is sort of the
thing right so how do we get i mean
functional programming is sort of um
isolated right all functional languages
they're about the program and most
systems are not a program they're n
programs
and uh so how do we get functional
programming benefits everywhere else
so i'm going to contend that uh
that a functional database must be
the value itself right if you're going
to have the notion of a value right
obviously um
you know we know where everybody let's
say we know everybody's email address in
this room right and then somebody
changes their email address there's some
novelty
uh
if if we're gonna have a notion of
values and we're gonna have new stuff
right then how do we keep the idea of a
value and and i think the way you do is
to if you're fully accretive that means
that you only add and you add like with
tree rings
then i think you can retain the notion
of a value because
at a certain ring of a tree and inside
that that never changes if you add new
rings that's not a problem there's a way
you can think about a database as being
a big value that extends over time and
as time passes you get to see more of
the value
and let's buy some nasty physics
philosophy something behind it
because otherwise what are you going to
do right there's not really an effective
way to do
a functional database with snapshots
it's far too expensive to do
but however you choose to do it and and
daytona chooses to be a creative
um you have to have immutability
you're not doing values
so i've been saying database and i think
we need to pull apart two different
notions of a database
uh we had this notion
a database system and this is really all
we ever had for data that's all we ever
talked about right the database was you
know it's running over there and you
talk to it and you send it messages and
it sends you answers that's a database
and now i think you need to split that
apart there is going to be that thing
and its job is to coordinate
right people have novelty they need to
send that novelty to someone who's going
to say okay i got your novelty got it i
understand i put it somewhere safe i got
yours yours didn't conflict with theirs
you know there's going to be a machine
that's going to coordinate
um
coordinate the process i'll call it of
creating and sharing novelty and growing
this value
and these things have identity right the
customer database
right this the product database
that is a thing that's whose identity is
the pr is stable and whose value differs
as time passes
right and if you're how many people are
closure programmers
okay
so this should sound familiar right
this identity
state value thing it's the same stuff
i only really have one idea
over and over again
and then so what i want to do is start
being able to talk about so that's the
database system and to a certain extent
um that means what it always used to
mean and then we have this database
value which is a very new thing you
can't go to oracle and say give me the
value of the database and it says okay
it just it doesn't um we don't have this
yet until you have systems like the
atomic um
and the values are the things that we
want to use for computation we don't
want to do we don't want to do
computation by a communication with this
moving target right that's what we end
up doing with databases right now it's
very difficult to understand what's
going to happen or what happened
so we can contrast these two things
right this is the database
as a process so this is a traditional
database works like this there's some
process
there's this novelty acquisition job
which we know is definitely the proper
part of this
process right people have new stuff they
talk to the database they say put this
in the database and david says okay i
got it
then
there's this left-hand side and that's
where it's ugly
right we have some computation we want
to do we have some function we want to
run on the database we want to get a
result
you know that function is a function of
what
when you show a query to a database it's
a function of what
maybe what's in the database at the time
it gets run depending on the read
concurrency
semantics that are set
and whether or not it's in a batch
i don't know i mean and most people
don't
and they get it wrong at least sometimes
so you have these questions right what
is allowed what are you allowed to do
well often
you know the database process completely
delimits what you're allowed to do
here's the query language this is what
you're allowed to ask you can't have
other stuff
and even as databases started to say oh
now you can run store procedures write
store procedures in java or c sharp or
whatever how many people are allowed to
do that at their company
i have none right
are you are you really allowed
to well
well usually you're not allowed
uh so so it's a fixed set of functions
right that you can run um can you get
reproduce the rule of zones right i want
to run a test i ran this thing
and now i'm like oh that doesn't that
looks kind of squirrely and i run it
again what happens
it's better
it got better how many people have ever
had a meeting where they said we were
having that problem earlier in the day
and then it got better
yeah that got worse
they often get worse but i mean getting
a better part when it gets better
i mean does that make you feel okay it's
like oh that's good
that's awesome it got better
that will never happen again
and the other problem with this you know
of course we don't really consider it an
inversion because it's all we've ever
had but it's really it's upside down
right and one of the problems with this
is that how do you have a function of
more than one database how many people
have ever set up like links databases
but you're like wow
that's
it's just doesn't work so you can't
really have a function of more than one
database because you send functions
inside a database and they run in this
context it's the opposite of arguments
it's out to say actually the opposite of
functions right you're not sending
arguments to function you're saying a
function to run inside this
space
so
what do we do with the functional
process
well
like i said this is important right this
is there is a job for the machine and it
is to take novelty and say got it i put
it somewhere you're good
because this is this is uh
this is change right so there has to be
something that does that it has to be
sort of machine-like and stateful
and then we're going to say all we're
going to be able to do
the only other thing we're going to be
able to do with that process is ask it
for values
that's it we took all the rest of the
stuff away there's no
there's no computation so where is the
computation
out please
get it out of there right take it out of
this process because that's our problem
right that's what's not functional about
this old model
so
what happens with computation
well
it's it's what we said before there's
going to be a function and it takes a
database value as an argument and it
produces some result
okay
what if we wanted to
have more than one database
okay usually we can have more than one
argument so we have more than one
argument
what if we wanted to
uh have a database as a result
that's okay too
right
and we have the same kind of thing the
same kind of questions actually all
right
all right so what's the lab
what's allowed in this function
what can you do
whatever you want right it's your
function you're writing in your own
programming language
arbitrary power i would hope
um
and uh can you get reproducible results
yeah
that's the same problem yeah you can use
more than one database and everything
else
so
as we look further at this you get more
value propositions one is that the
database that's a value is just data all
right and therefore it's not an api it's
not an object with a special set of
stuff it's sort of a language
independent idea data
right a map or a list or a vector it's
not like
no language owns those things and every
language can sort of reach them
and being data means you can do
arbitrary aggregation arbitrary
composition which is very difficult to
do with
objective kind of things or apis you
really can't compose apis and get
semantics that you understand
and the other value proposition you get
are the value propositions of persistent
data structures just like the ones you
when you use them in memory and people
know what i'm talking about when i say
persistent data structure in memory okay
that's good enough everybody else can
ask everybody else
so those those benefits are alias
freedom right i don't care i can i can
if i have a value of database i can give
it to you and i don't have to worry oh
i hope they don't screw me over later
because i gave them access to my
database body and how many people feel
that way about strings actually depends
what
using languages elijah who'd say
many people language you're
strength
how about numbers like if you gave
somebody 42 who would be worried
no you're not worried about this thing
you can change
so generally
we don't worry about things like that
and that's a really good thing
because that that allows you to build
programs that
share a lot but don't worry a lot
and the other value proposition you get
in persistent data structures is that
change isn't like copy the whole world
to get a new world plus one thing right
change is incremental and it's made
efficient
so the cool thing about this is that you
end up with this one structure
associated with the database but you can
get a lot of functions daytonic supports
data log queries natively but there's no
reason you can have other query
languages because you have everything
that i have for everything that i had to
write data log for data you have and you
can write your own language that you you
know that satisfies you
because it's reverted control query
languages you can have a lot of them
you can get direct index
access to the indexes which is another
big feature right because that's really
the leverage part
right if the database is giving you
leverage then saying here
have that um it should give you that
leverage how people have wished they
could directly access the indexes in the
sql database
yeah
without causing parts
and then finally you can also you know
just looking at the same exact structure
do
um
objective or graph like things right or
document
like things by navigating through
entities and relationships and things
like that you pick your pick your poison
or take whichever
view of the world you want that makes
sense
so one of the cool things about having
persistent data structures in the
database architecture this way is you
can do speculation
you can say i have this value of the
database i wonder what it would be like
if i added this data i don't actually
want to submit this data to the process
yet because i don't know what's going to
happen
right i want to try it and see what the
resulting database value looks like
maybe issue some queries and then say
that all looks good
or maybe
i'm just doing um
prediction and i don't ever need to
store this i'm just going to say what if
we sold three times as much stuff next
week would would uh
would we have enough inventory or would
our shipping supply lines work you can
go and get that answer you don't have to
like change the database that
everybody's looking at in order to get
that answer
and when you want to do backtracking you
just sort of drop the value you created
and go back to a previous value
that's actually the most important thing
that bank does
what happens if interest rates go this
way yes
yeah so it's is it's easy to do that the
atomic has a construct called with which
takes a database value and this the data
you would have sent to a transaction the
data you would have sent to the process
if you were going to issue a transaction
and you can just send them both to this
function with and you get back the
database you would have gotten
you issued that transaction
and and people people do this a lot and
do very sophisticated things it was we
have one customer who's doing like this
event propagation where events go to
children go to children go to children
and what happens to the children you
have to calculate using a query that
already includes what happens to the
parents and they just write this
beautiful little recursive function with
width that propagates the change and
every sub
computation sees the new view of the
database
what do you have i mean how do you do
speculation with place oriented
databases
oh you roll back right you issue a
transaction hope you don't screw anybody
over and you roll back
until you lock the entire until
the other thing that you can do if
you're creative is you can do time
travel and so i sort of contrasted i'm
not going to get enough time to sort of
dig into it but the two possible worlds
for doing a functional immutable
database are you could do snapshots
which i don't really think is practical
or you can do the secretion thing and
when you use the accretion model it
means that every value of the database
contains all the old values of the
database like any one value contains
everything that happened in the past
which means that if you have a value in
the database you can query
anything as if it was a point in time
earlier
so if you have the tree ring you know
out here you can say let's just pretend
it was here and give me the answer about
this
um so you can say as of a point in time
or sends a point in time you know from
here out to there
you can also query across time right
because if i can take a database and say
let me see you as if it was last tuesday
and
i can write functions that take more
than one database
and and saying let me see you as if it
was last tuesday it doesn't change this
but i could say now
last tuesday pass now and last tuesday
to aquari
and query across time
flattening between these two things or
what's the ratio between us and that
it just sort of changes everything
it changes testing
right how many people like testing
databases
that word mock
keeps coming up
it's not it's it's not going in favor of
the humans the mocking and the system
uh it's going the other way
right because what do you do right when
a database is a place and and
interacting with the database is a
conversation how do you pretend right
because testing is like you pretend you
pretend this happened and you see what
that happened so how do you pretend
like
these connections they're they're pretty
much for real right so you have to
either create an entire other database
and completely put it in a in a state
and do this other thing or what do you
do you put in a mock where what
everything always works oh yeah that's
fine oh that's good okay
right this is the mock it's just like
happily doing you know pretending to do
whatever you're asked to do
and like how difficult is it to make
reproducible tests then well unless
you're going to start from absolute
blank every time and build up to a
precisely known point it's very very
difficult to make reproducible tests
whereas if you have a value-oriented
database
you don't flow around connections right
most of your code is written in terms of
the values
so especially if you can fabricate
values and as you you'll see in a little
bit
as soon as i push the
specific you can know
past values you can go with the past
value but also because it's values and
it's just data how many people have
programming language where they can make
up data in a program
that's awesome that's the program
and if all you needed was data to test
the query
you could do that you don't even need a
database you could just make it up
and that's sort of one of the value
propositions of values itself right when
you program with values
you can generate them easily in programs
which means you can write tests and
things like that
so i i mentioned earlier about
information models let me just
describe what i mean by that
uh
of course i love the dictionary
it helps me write talks
and
this is what i found for information
which is to convey knowledge by effects
right and to give shape to the mind or
help people make decisions i think this
is why we have databases right
i mean of course i just talked to
somebody who has a database that
you know the real main purpose of it is
to just keep everything forever in case
they get audited right
which is another
you know it's a valid reason because you
need to know the facts of what happened
before
but but especially those kinds of
databases are in particular fact
oriented right they're not place
oriented you get a new thing you don't
go like i'm going to erase what it
already has right that's that what does
that do to your audibility
so so that that sort of takes us to like
what does fact mean which is this is the
key here this is the key to everything
the key to moving away from databases is
places to keep your you know stuff
to
something richer which is that a fact is
something that happened
in fact some a fact is something that
already happened
right it literally means something done
right
and there's two things about that that
are interesting one is it can't change
because you can't change the past right
and the other is it has to include time
right
we build up the you know primitive
notion of a fact sally
how many people are satisfied with that
as a fact
sally likes
nobody's buying it sally likes pizza
is it a fact
some nuts but you know it's a trick
question
so you place your bets no i mean has
sally always liked pizza forever how
about before sally try pizza
will she always like pizza
no
if you know salad likes pizza you know a
very particular thing at this point in
time sally likes pizza
similarly sally has an email address
forever and ever and ever no
especially
so so so facts are things that happen so
when sally gets a new email address it's
not like the universe came to sally's
email address place and
substituted something different there
that's not what happened right it's a
new fact happened at a new time and
everything about it is novel so you have
to incorporate time and so we have our
primitive thing it's a lot like rdf
right this primitive thing with entity
attribute value plus time gives you what
i would consider to be a pact
and what atomic treats is sort of the
primitive data representation
so i talked about the database as an
expanding value well here's my tree
rings
this is a terrible slide because i don't
think you can see them but they're
triggered
right so the database is this expanding
value already described this you're sort
of discovering what it is it's just an
accretion of facts you never change the
path which you don't in real life either
right it also means that process
requires new space and this is where
people freak out
right this is where people freaked out
when you said persistent data structures
in memory same thing like oh my god copy
it right
the world is going to end right i'm
going to run out of memory
there's not that much change in the
world right
there really isn't i mean take what take
take your business just
until you're doing weather
whether but still as a percentage
right it just can't keep going
indefinitely
so this is a monotonically increasing
model yeah doesn't that lead to
scalability issues at some point
no that's what i'm saying i mean if
you're applying this to business
problems right if your business is
doubling every year hoo-ha but like for
how long
i mean it's just not going to keep
happening is it strong
storage is beating you it's already
beating you it will continue to beat you
it's not beating you for the scientific
problem that's for sure terabytes of
data are coming in every day so there
are logging categories of problems where
i i think that this this you still need
the persistence this is true you have to
buy more discs all the time well i mean
that's what this says it says process
requires new space so i mean can you
afford it or not i mean it's an
independent question if you can't you
can't
um but it's it doesn't rule out this
approach and most people i think are not
um
uh
quite aware of how little novelty they
have as a percentage of all the
information they're maintaining and in
the end people need audit trails for
anything that's you're already doing
this yeah how many people use git i mean
source code's not that big
but you know we don't overwrite you know
we don't just keep our files and our
source code in like directories
i have that you know updating if by just
replacing
and businesses want this right how many
people are mining logs
yeah one is a lot it's an accretive
thing with no leverage that's what it is
it's the same thing maybe you want to
throw stuff away later and for different
reasons we can talk about that um but
the fundamental thing is you're moving
away from places whether you keep it all
forever or not you're still not going to
the email address place of sally and
substituting something
because you're no longer interested so
that would be forgetting it's sort of
like uh worms eating homes
but you're still you say stock market
data for example
it's kind of like a
it's a sliding window yeah
yeah so i mean some of that some of that
is a good fit and some of it is not
you know i i i'm not saying this is
universally applicable uh and you have
to assess your your problem um daytonic
does have excision which allows you to
forget and it's still fundamentally
different to never change anything and
to forget things than it is to update
things in place right yeah sort of the
big the big idea so we're moving away
from places
right um i talked a little bit about
snapshots or whatever but the bottom
line is
you can't create a new group right if
you're going to have persistent data
structures in memory what do you do
every time you have a new change
they're trees right and every time you
have a change you
uh
copy the path from the root to the new
leaf and then the tree shares all the
rest of the old tree except the path to
the novelty
which means you're producing a new root
every time something new happens but
what happens in memory when you do that
it comes to the old roots
they hit garbage cart right
they get guards like magic this is good
and and how do you hand off the
novelty
well it's sort of automatic your program
has created these new routes and sort of
as long as it doesn't like drop it
it's sort of it's a handoff system it's
just handing off here's the new thing
here's a new thing
um if you're going to have processes
come and go
maybe all the processes are down and
then they all come back up and there's a
database in the middle there's no
hand-off strategy the database would
have to maintain a route and ends up you
just cannot afford to maintain a route
for every for every piece of novelty
so you can't do that you can't do a
group transaction you can't uh
you can't do
snapshots
so you make the latest value include all
of the past as well and so essentially
you have this big tree and you just keep
adding new things to the tree
and that's that's important for the
information well
um
i don't know if i talk more about that
later that means it has to be
implemented using
using mutation
you know there's an exposed mutation no
no no no no
no it just implements in this single
tree as opposed to a series of trees
with new roots
um so what ends up happening uh oh so so
i i don't talk about it on the slide but
i'll because she asked right yeah so
what ends up to do this to do this
properly um you need to combine
a memory persistent data structure and
an adorable one
because you do need to produce a new
root every piece of novelty but not in
durable end which means you're going to
log everything because you need to make
sure it's durable when somebody says
here's my new stuff and the process says
okay i got it you want that to be true
um but that doesn't have to be
leveraged that can just be sort of a
depend thing that logging
then what what you do is the same
technique that bigtable and other things
use you you accumulate a bunch of
novelty and memory and you you provide
the leverage there with the persistent
sorted data structure in memory and that
one you can rely on garbage collection
to just you know clean up the roots and
periodically that will grow to a certain
size it'll say 64 meg's worth right and
then you'll um
amortize the cost of integrating that in
the big durable tree
so you're not producing a new durable
route every transaction you're acquiring
a whole bunch of novelty and then
merging that in
and that's how it works
so any query is actually going to be a
merge join between a certain amount of
novelty that's in memory and the last
time it was integrated
in storage
right
is the disc treated as a law
there are two things
on storage yeah
one is
an index or set of indexes which are big
trees right and the other is a log which
is another big trade the log semantics
are append
and index semantics are merged
right the index is sorted it has the
leverage part okay the log is just i i
got it so this is riser
well i mean who i don't know this first
there's a whole bunch of things that do
this
but they they all they all work this way
because it's a bit you're forced into it
if you think about this long enough
you're forced into this answer you know
you're gonna you need a persistent data
structure you have to amortize
um
and so this is how you do the
amortization
okay
and then we have process right which is
submitting novelty and the key there is
that we don't want that to be all like
touchy-feely api oriented we want that
to be reified we want to say this is the
novelty and this novelty is data
right it has a representation as data
not as function calls change blah blah
blah
you know it's just like here's the data
so we represent the the novelty as
assertions and retractions of facts
that's the minimal thing you can build
higher level things um in terms of those
right so you can you can build functions
that yield assertions and retractions
and that's how you build up a system
that can have a higher higher level
semantics
but it's important then that this
representation is minimal so when people
are concerned about storage one of the
things they're concerned about is if i
have this big record and i keep changing
sally's email address and i'm going to
rewrite this record every time well
that's already it's like time out that's
like the people who presumed that
persistent data structures were going to
be copied on right people who are saying
well every time i change the email
address i have to write a new row or
document that'll kill me it would kill
you
right you need to make sure that your
represent representation of novelty is
just the novelty
i'm not i didn't change all of sally
i knew a new fact about sally's email
address that's it and that's all that's
in there and that's all that's going to
get written not rewriting
a sally entity or document or row and
because it's temporarily qualified we
don't care if it
can't flip it you can't complete
time thing
sally's like in the star trek episode
the attraction is assertion that there's
no longer a fact here that's correct at
this point yeah we no longer know what
size you know this is
you can do that you can either no longer
know it or say this is the value from
here or forward
but if you skip back in time you see the
old one can you assert negative things
that this is not sally's emotions no you
can't do any of that so this is not a
semantic
uh web database
and there are those and so one of the
reasons why i made this was because i
had actually tried to use those kinds of
databases for business
use as a database and it's a misfit
there's nothing wrong with those things
they have a lot of power and you can
solve a bunch of interesting problems
with them they're not necessarily a good
fit for the things businesses use
databases for we constantly run into
into false facts where we do not know
the true facts yeah that's why i asked
about that which is hard and yeah we we
we believe that somebody was born on
april 17th you know 1854 then we find
out that this is not true and we don't
know when he was born
yeah well you can just retract you could
just straight retractor then you would
you then you then the database would
seem to not know that right that's what
i was asking right um so it's like you
know
a double entry kind of yeah you know
it's hard but that's the truth
uh i'm not gonna talk about this too
much this is what traditional databases
are like i mean the things that you know
is that this is big server and it does
everything that's important
and then communicate to it using strings
and and that
if you want a prayer of having good
performance you have to remember the
answers you got earlier
and stick the answers in the cache
it's kind of like everything was before
this is the before yeah okay so this is
the after this is the afternoon
and and then the bottom line i know
again i'm not gonna really dig into this
too much but the the thing that the
atomic does is it just breaks this apart
and turns everything upside down
just do that and you end up with a
different database
so uh so what we do is we we
we
limit the job of
uh
what we call the transactor to just that
process part of the job it happens to be
the case that currently we run indexing
on the same box but that's not important
it could run on a different box but the
job of transaction management is the job
that is only that
it's just
you've said there's this novelty i said
i got it you said this is honestly i
said i got it in addition the transactor
will ensure a monotonic single ordering
of the entire world because the atomic
is oriented around consistency that's
consistent rights
um yeah so the index has to like sort of
merge in the new information i'll show
you indexing
more pictures later
like there's one thing that's the
physical index and then one thing that's
here yeah i have a picture that goes
like this on the next slide let me
finish with this one
so there's something that just does
transaction coordination is something
that just does index merging
right
storage we separate out so it used to be
you know that the storage was the
prominence of the the master
you know uh server and inside it
literally inside it and that's an
architecture born of well those big
machines used to be really expensive and
you only had one so obviously that
machine is in charge of the storage
thing
but that doesn't make any sense anymore
uh so now what we do is we just say
that's a logical thing of storage
servers daytona treats storage services
like
like the old databases used to treat
file systems it sticks chunks of indexes
in them but what could be a storage
service anything including other
databases
you know a sql database can be that
dynamodb can be that we can run and
finish fan and memory react couch base
all these things can serve as storages
uh underneath daytime we treat them all
the same like key value stores where
this is key and this immutable value a
big chunk of the inside of an index we
don't use any of the other capabilities
of the storages
but it means you can make independent
decisions about storages and should you
adopt a storage that has um scaling
characteristics and elasticity
characteristics you like like either
react something like it on premise or
dynamodb uh on aws
you get those benefits because you'll
see there's a line from storage up to
what we call the application server
process which is just your program but
they're generally the application server
parts of your program where you're going
to be running a library
that includes the query so we've moved
query out of the server up into the
what we call peers right these
applications
and how many of those can you
have as you want
so now you're seeing you're going to get
horizontal scalability
of queries right and this if you pick a
similarly scalable storage
that part is completely independent
because this live index
right the novelty that comes into the
transactor is actually reflected to the
peers remember this is just the novel
stuff it accumulates to a certain point
and then gets spooled out at which point
you can drop it
each pier has got a copy of the live
index
so far
and the ability to reach storage
with those two things it can answer
queries it can pull as much or as little
as it needs to answer queries every peer
doesn't get the entire database doesn't
need the entire database
and and what's coming out of here is
immutable
right so novelty comes in there you
update a persistent data structure
that's what that live index is it's a
it's a persistent data structure in
memory in here are indexes which are
persistent data structures on storage
durable
and since this is immutable can you
cache it
you can cache it
like there's no stop where can you cash
it
anywhere you want
how many times can you cash it
how many times you have to worry about
cash coherency
when the transactor falls down that's
when you run it
appears to be ass so how do we fix that
no you don't fix that that's that is a
that is a trade-off the atomic mix it
says you have traditional scalability on
the rights and you have new school
scalability on the reeds
because because right now i think we
have this world where we have this
extreme
you get the big server that does
everything that's really difficult to
scale in any direction and you get
inconsistent databases which scale but
like you never know what's going to
happen right
but you know people run the windows
are used to the idea that they never
know what's going to happen
i'm not dictating what to choose i'm
just saying there seems to be this giant
gap in between these two things and
that's what they come with targets
because because it is really consistent
it is acid um it has those properties
and it ends up that you know if you read
the research
um
if you take everything out of that
transactor like it doesn't it doesn't
handle any query load or anything else
um
it's
a lot of businesses cannot override it's
just you just ran as fast as your disk
yeah
yeah
and also you don't really need to worry
that you haven't gotten the latest data
at least you've got something consistent
as of a certain time correct right
that's right yeah that's right you
always have you always have a view that
is that is consistent what i would call
business rules consistent
right you never see half of a
transaction or half of anything or
something that doesn't doesn't make
sense if you need to wait until
everything up until a certain time is
probably processed you just wait
yeah and there's a bunch of ways to do
that there are these api calls called
sync that give you multiple different
flavors because the monotonic timeline
has identity of the points in time you
can actually communicate those very
cheaply
and so if you said i created something
over here and out of band i communicated
to you that i did that i could say what
the time point of that was and you could
say i don't want to act upon that until
i see
the view of the world that includes that
point in time
or you there's another flavor of sync
which will actually ping through the
server which is sort of like the
zookeeper model of knowing that um
to order events happens before right you
can force the happens before
um scenario by pinging through the
server and waiting for it to come back
so yeah
the latest does that make any sense to
say that latest is just uh so the latest
is always getting pushed and and right
so what i said before is you don't
really program in terms of connections
but if you ask the connection for the
value the database that is the latest
value it knows about right that's right
if you call sync you'll know you'll get
the value of the database um that is
definitely
uh
after
right the sync call that's right
are these times like what clock times or
the internal time there's an internal
time but we also associate with this
time of the transactor of receipt
but transactions are first-class
entities you can assert facts about
transactions like this was my real world
idea of the time or this is who did it
or what process did it or any you can
make facts about transactions because
transactions are first class you can
touch them you can get the data we'll
see that in a second hopefully okay let
me move a little bit more quickly so
actually i almost have slides
so i can show you show you the database
in action so this is interesting we saw
a memcache cluster on the picture before
this what was in it
no no in the old databases what do you
put in your memcache
answers
answers to what
old questions old answers to old
questions
what do you do with those things
42. here you go
who wants it
is it good
how do you know
like this is this is a nightmare right
as you say things don't change all that
much or cash wouldn't work well you
wouldn't know
whose problem is it it's your problem
right you have to listen to transactions
that are happening in the database to
update your campaign yeah it's it's very
difficult what's in here
sources of answers to questions same
stuff that's in the database yeah
and that ends up being a lot more
reusable
and then you can cash in cash and cash
you want to see a picture look like this
so this is this is what's happening
right transactions are coming in they
immediately get logged to storage in an
appendy way and they get transmitted to
all the live indexes that are connected
right at some point later an index
merging process is going to go and
siphon everything out of that live index
and merge it into storage and create a
new
uh
a new value and storage so obviously
there will be there will be different
values of these trees but they'll be
very infrequent not a new route for
every transaction
right but how do we find the value of
the database
how do we find the customer database
tree
index so this is that identity problem
right
so closure people right what do we do
with identities what what set of
constructs do we have for our identities
the reference types right reference atom
right those kinds of things well it ends
up that you do need something like that
you need something that's always got the
same name you know the customer database
group right here that you can
swap something into so it ends up that
you can build the entire the entirety of
daytonic with
five of those on disk and one in memory
that's the total number of variables
that you need to build a system this is
a huge system
that's it that's all the variables you
need of the five
uh
there's a there's a
several in storage for the roots of the
different indexes
there's something that coordinates
who is the transactor for this database
and then in memory it's just the root of
that live index
is inside an atom a closure atom
everything goes through the index to get
storage you have to kind of
go to the index first performance you
don't have to re-read that you don't
have to re-read that root because you're
informed you're informed when when you
move to a new tree until until you're
informed of that you once you've
de-referenced that
that cell to find out the root that root
is valid
until you're told about the next one
so you do not need to keep dereferencing
that stuff right but it does mean it
kind of includes the index the currency
of the index
and you would go through that define
you're always going to have the identity
of the root node but this is the
immutable root okay right you don't need
to go through the mutable identity thing
over and over
now that would be a catastrophe if you
need to do that but it does mean that
storage is in addition to the bulk of
the work that they do which is storing
immutable values do need to have the
semantics necessary to do the equivalent
of a closure atom in storage which means
they need the moral equivalent of kaz
compare and swap
in storage right so sql databases have
that and it ends up that dynamo has that
but it ends up databases like reop do
not have that
so for databases like react we split the
job up and we say riak you can deal with
all the immutable stuff because you're
eventually consistent that's all you
could do correctly
and then we supplement a react with
something like zookeeper which can do
distributed cats
and that's we just put the five
references in zookeeper when we put all
the values in react and combine the two
but you do need both those capabilities
from storage when we want to issue a
query that's like perception right it's
again it's the closure model perceiving
things shouldn't interfere with process
has nothing to do with process so i
issue a query i need to
access the novelty and access storage
and merge them together and run my
function on the merge
what is coordination in this
prison where do we talk to the
transactor in this
don't do that
can we make this horizontally scalable
yeah
right
process and perception you want to
bring a tower apart
okay
this is where it gets scary
press a i have to use my
computer in front of people
my secret problem is i don't know how to
use computers
that's always bad
all right
the other thing that's always amusing
for people is in addition to being bad
at computers i'm really bad at um
for this audience it's gonna be
hilarious
is that all right or no yes
let's have a vote it's like uh
i test
is this better you know the opposition
is this better or is this better
second all right
i'll make this smaller
okay
you've just seen the extent of my no i
have one more thing i know how to do
anyway
i'm exhausted so the way i'm going to do
this i'm just going to move my curse
around up here and the only thing i had
to do is control option x which executes
where my cursor is so we'll load up the
atomic and then
some pretty print stuff out if i even
use this
and i think my server's still running i
think the machine doesn't fall asleep
yeah okay good
so uh we load the atomic api which is
really tiny we get p print we're gonna
just make this helper function that
creates a temp id
i'm not gonna have time to talk about
these namespace things but daytonic
follows the namespace
approach of closure in that namespaces
are important
so we're going to use them
so when we talk about database it has
identity we like these databases when
possible to have global identity so when
you use something like
dynamo that's something that you know
anybody's database and anybody else's
database have names that don't perform
when you start using local resources
well then it's a little bit on you but
the idea is that you use the uri to name
the database so there's a protocol then
where is it and then that's the database
name and then we create a database
saying create database and use the uri
and that should say i did it or i didn't
do it which means it was already there
otherwise you get a failure
now we're going to see this connection
right which is we're creating connection
this is the process part
you're going to see we use this very
infrequently that's the idea behind
atomic that you don't use it very often
you're going to send transactions over
this connection every now and then
you're going to ask the connection for
the value of the database but remember
that diagram right that was the only two
things connections to how to do take new
stuff and give you the value of the
database
so that's what we do so we make a
connection to the database
we do everything with atomic with data
so for the lispers that are not uh
closure people
but one thing closure does
is
radically controversial
is it it provides literals that have the
same power as lists do
for vectors and
sets and associative maps
and they're all immutable
and uh
it's kind of a big deal it's
how i get that argument in this room
about that
so
so schema is represented as data and i
like to again get into this but you can
sort of get the gist of it in in
daytonic the only schema we have are the
definitions of attributes we said entity
attribute value there's no notion of
classes or record types or anything
bigger than attribute but an attribute
does have a definition that says whether
or not it's unique what kind of what
type of values can it take on what the
cardinality relationships are
and things like that and then where
where where it lives and what its name
is so this just sets up a single
attribute called email
that we're going to use for this demo
and
by saying defschema i just now have
that value in that variable but i
haven't done anything with it yet um so
i didn't i didn't change the database
but now i'm going to change the database
for the first time i'm going to issue a
transaction
through the connection and i'm going to
pass the schema you can pass more than
one thing so you always pass a
collection
of
things to transactions that's why it's
in
in a vector so it's a vector that has
one thing in it and effectively this
this map
is just sugar for saying the same entity
has a dbid of this and an identity of
that and the value type of this these
are all triples
right what are they missing
the time part right but the time part is
going to be established by the
transactor when it arrives
so you just have nc attribute value so
by using a map you're just saying for
the same entity
it's presumed the e part and this is all
just now
attribute value attribute value
attribute value because it's the same e
if you want to collect like historical
data that definitely happened in the
past like before i install my database
can i provide my own times yes you can
once and
once through as long as you don't lie
okay
so you can't go to the future and you
can't do stuff out of order but you can
see the database with historical times
you can assert what the transaction
times were for
seed data
so once you once you once you give
something without a
historical time then
you have to always you can never give
them a certain remember i know you can
as long as you never conflict with with
anything that's in there you can't
create out of order time you can do
everything else but that's only
transaction time it's not internal time
of the of
a temporal event yeah you know you can
you can assert somebody's birthday you
know it was in 960 and then somebody
else's birthday was 90 58. yeah that's
different
is and it's very important to note that
daytona's
notion of time is the time of the
database value itself
not about the events in the world right
it's not it's about going around in time
in the value of the database itself
because that's the only time i can
manage you could tell me any arbitrary
stuff i can't be in charge of whether or
not that's correct
it's about when you knew about it no
well when it's when the database
it's actually the rings themselves each
one is like you can imagine each one
being a transaction are there
restrictions on the values
um like what types of what action types
do you have yeah um there's a set that's
supported
we do have the technology under the hood
to allow that to be extensible uh we
haven't exposed that yet but it's only
possible
so now
this is just something i missed uh you
mentioned that
we have a map there um obviously those
are the
attribute value uh the entity is the
enti what's the entity
the entity is uh because we're we're
asserting that its id is a temporary id
the database is going to say this is a
new it this is all about entity that i
don't know about yet
and therefore i'm going to supply a new
entity id for it
so you're creating an anonymous entity
correct and it will know
and that entity that anonymous entity
tells you how to interpret the email
attribute later
yes it basically just all these facts
are going to be associated with the same
entity ncids are not actually semantic
they're supplied by databases of just
numbers the semantics come from what you
said about it which is how it should be
right
so if you have multiple schemas you're
only using one in this example yes can
you refer across each other with things
like foreign key constraints
there's no there's no constraints so
that's definitely an area where this is
challenged when compared to a
row oriented database because row
oriented databases
know that there's a relationship between
attributes that applies to a thing and
it will always have all the attributes
you would have to do anything like that
yourself
i'm not going to get to talk about
transaction functions much but that's a
tool you can use to do your own
enforcement of arbitrary constraints and
when you do that you can enforce
constraints that cross things that you
can't do with foreign keys you can
really you can do arbitrary constraints
because this is that consistent with all
known facts
anything you want to say application
because essentially a constraint is a
function of the value of the database
anything you want
this is maybe way out there but uh you
know in addition to b-tree indexes you
know now you know press for example
you've got
uh full text indexes
yes
you know geo location
data
does does atomic allow for you know
a wide variety of different kinds of
indexes we don't have pluggable indexes
we do have full text
and we've had a fair number of requests
for the geo so i'll probably do
something
okay let me let's let's put something in
there
uh so we have the schema it's this value
we're putting it in a vector because
we're gonna send a set of values and
it's just
this one guy
um
and then we're gonna say transact to the
connection so this data gets sent over
the wire and this this is i'm actually
running over the wire you can run the
atomic memory but this i'm running the
transactor server as another process
over here
so we issue this thing and we get back a
return value from issuing a transaction
so what's in that it ends up that that's
a map i'm just going to look at the keys
of that map
right so i got back a map from this call
the keys are really interesting
i issued a transaction i got back the
database before the transaction
the value of the database before the
transaction
the value of the database after the
transaction immediately after the
transaction immediately before
how many people have ever wished they
could go back to the databases
always always always get these two
values
the data that was produced by the
transaction right because there are
these transaction functions that might
expand into assertions and retractions
they might actually query the database
and find out new stuff so what actually
got asserted by this transaction
right
when you look at a sql transaction how
do you know what's going to happen
or what happened
no idea you just don't have a number
yeah you don't know um
you know sometimes it's just a matter of
saying you know what maybe it even
though it's always like this maybe it
shouldn't be like this
you know it's always been like this
maybe it shouldn't be and then we get
any temporary id so this is actually a
map the temp ideas is a map from
uh the temp id you generated which if
you had held on to in your program would
be some arbitrary thing yeah and the
actual entity id that got created in the
database so you can then go and say oh
this temporary id became this concrete
id and i can use that to sew together
new stuff so all these things you always
wish you had you get all the time
uh every every query
so now we're going to capture the value
of the database after this transaction
we're going to call it new db just so we
can talk about things later
so one of the things we want to do is
say is the new db the same as the
database before
the the before the transaction and we're
going to use equals to do that
the value is um
it's just like a little data structure
that has roots okay yeah that's it
just the identities of roots that's
right
yeah
so we can use equals to determine if the
two databases are the same
and then we can see is that we're going
to go say is the new database the same
as asking for the database from the
connection so db of connection is like
the latest right somebody said how do
you get latest just ask the connection
for the latest value of db that actually
doesn't go over the wire
because everything's getting pushed to
you
over the connection when you ask this
question you immediately get an answer
it's whatever most recent value we were
told so when you ask for the database
value you actually have it oakley
when you have what can you ask for the
database you already have
yeah you're right that's why you don't
need to catch them
well
um or another point of view i don't go i
don't go across the connect i don't go
over the wire to answer this thing the
connection
idea is still there and it's still
behaving the same way
but there's push going on so why
why call when you can push
so now we can say is this the same now
if there were other people around
messing with my machine which hopefully
no one's doing right now
what this answer we don't know what this
answer is right so it says is the
database right after i issued the schema
transaction the same as a database like
i'm going to go ask for the database
value right now
this is not necessarily going to be true
but if no one else is messing with my
machine
it is going to be true and for the
purposes of this
um demo that will continue to be the
case
so this is like asking has anything
changed
has anything else yeah has anything else
changed that's right
so queries also data
there's a bunch of things this is
slightly a sugared version of it which
is easier for people who don't know
closure and
don't like writing nested data
structures to write but there's a mac
version that's only slightly more
verbose that's
more regular
and so query is just data in this case
we say find
some
that variable e and email
where
ease email addresses email basically
this is a way of saying get me all the
emails all the entities and their email
so we're not doing this right now we're
just taking a piece of data and calling
it query
in order to issue a query
uh we have to call q which is the
function that does a query
and we pass it the query
and the database to query what is
missing from this call
connection
we're there
and there's no emails in this database
we made that we defined that email is an
attribute but we didn't say anybody had
email addresses yet we just said that
email address is a thing you could have
all right so let's make somebody with an
email address how does he know that
colon email means what you said it meant
and not what somebody else said and then
somewhere else
that's what namespaces are for this
example does not have
namespaces in it it's very bad of me to
have done that
but but apparently the namespaces freak
out people
they're like oh my god there's a thing
and then a splash
so but but any any real use of data all
of those names would be name space and
that gives you a nice conflict-free way
to have different things but what's cool
is that um it's not like you have to
have walled gardens
if there are attributes that truly are
semantically shared between things you
can share them right they're not inside
rows or inside record definitions they
really can be shared so depending on
what your needs are so let's put an
actual user in so we're going to say
same kind of thing
we're going to say transact across the
connection we're going to supply a list
of of transaction values we're going to
use that map technique to create an
anonymous
new guy whose email
fred at email.com
and we're going to issue this
transaction we get a return value again
same thing is in there before or after
what the stuff is whatever so let's look
at those temp ids
and we see the temp id negative 950 blah
blah blah became one seven five nine
vote
there are ways actually to call
functions and get like what the t time
of this thing was and stuff like that um
i know that's not a very pretty number
are temp id is always negative or is
that an accident
they're always negative
oops
now i'm going to make a helper i'm going
to grab
fred's id so we take that return value
and
the temp id's out of it
and the first one of those and grab its
value
so this is just piping just just takes
all your
parentheses and
makes them go away
but it does what you think it just does
it in the opposite order which is the
way everybody else thinks
so there you go
we just
however you want to think we'll just
like make you
happy it's it's undeniably more
concisely has less
so another thing this this also gives
you is like like any other triple star
or whatever you can
add your own attributes to someone
else's object yes you can yep
yep yep so uh so that's a useful
function we're just going to name it
we'll call it i don't like your face
which is adding my attribute to the
object
i know rich has a hard stop time so do
we yeah
yeah let me let me let me go a little
bit faster but you know i'm happy to
have it be any combination but we will
have
we'll have to stop soon uh so let me try
to get through this so remember new db
when did we grab new db
right after we
issued the schema so if we
send the query to new db having added
fred what will we see
hopefully nothing right if that mess
with nudib
we don't have values
nothing can change new db nothing can
change the answer of this query on new
db ever ever ever ever
that's the beautiful thing so if you
have a whole bunch of queries you need
to do to do analyses you can have the
same basis and keep using the same value
over and over you're going to get the
same answers and you're going to have
stuff that correlates
i mean people ever tried to issue a
report that involved multiple queries
and then the numbers didn't add up
yeah i mean what can you do
you just actually have no tools to to
make it work
so if we want to now capture the value
of the database after we did
fred
we're going to do that we're going to
call it the freddy b now if we issue the
query against spread db what are we
going to say
fred fred's email right we wanted to
answer the id and the email that's what
we asked for so we'll do another
transaction just adding ethyl exactly
the same way we did fred
get the same kind of return value
write the database after we're going to
call the etheldb this is the value of
database after doing it so we now have
nu
which is after the schema
fred which is after fred ethel which is
after effort right and same thing fred
db doesn't change f load to b has what
fred and ethel
right and if we go back to over the
connections the latest what about the
latest does anybody get on my machine no
still secure
apparently nsa is not interested in this
so now let's look at speculation i
talked about speculations let's look at
speculation so you're a newcomer to
atomic this is all very very strange
everything's upside down
somebody asked you to go and change
freddie fred's name to freddie
maybe you're not sure how to do that
so you heard about the speculation thing
and this function called with so instead
of issuing a transaction you want to try
with you're going to say i don't really
know what i'm doing yet let me try to
make this update to fred's email to
change it to freddie so we want to do is
create a friday transaction that sets
email to
freddie email.com so we make this
transaction now instead of sending it
we're going to send it to the connection
but instead of using transact
and actually we're not sending it to the
connection we're going to get the value
of the database the current value of the
database out of the connection
we're going to take that value of the
database and send it to with
right so instead of sending a
transaction to
a connection we're going to send the
database
and this transaction to with which just
gives us a new database in memory
it doesn't doesn't go across the wire
and we're going to get the after value
of that and we're going to call that the
freddie db
now what's in the freddie db
three things
we did not do this correctly
what happened to us
generated a new id yeah we asked for a
new entity we didn't we didn't actually
change fred
we just made up a new new guy called
freddie but did we mess anything up
no
we didn't send this we didn't issue this
transaction yet so let's fix it remember
before we grab fred's id out of the um
temp id thing told us what fred's id was
after he had been great because we can't
know that in advance but we can save it
after the
query this is what we want to do right
say fred's email is now this
and that will say that's the freddie
transaction and now
we're going to try this in memory again
get the latest value of the database
pass it to with with this transaction
that's going to return the same stuff a
real transaction wouldn't we'll get the
after value out of that we call it
freddie db and now issued aquarium
whatever we get
freddie and ethel
so we're good
now that we're good let's actually do it
this is nice this is like i i don't know
i don't get fired database
we didn't we don't change anything this
freddy transaction was data we just
tried it with with we can say that same
exact data precisely to transact
and this is how we do it for real now
and so now
this friday db is the value returned by
transact and it did really happen if we
go back across the connection and ask
for the latest value database we did we
did change something that everybody will
see
all right let's quickly look at history
if we grab the latest value of the
database we're going to call it the
latest value of the database and we can
issue the query on that and we see this
but what i told you was
databases are accretive
databases are accretive which means that
they have all of the history before them
so
we can actually issue a query that
crosses history this basically lifts the
the fact that normally query is going to
show you
the most recent value of every attribute
present in a database so when i asked
for fred's email address it said freddie
because that's the value that was there
but fred is still in there somewhere so
i can issue a quick i can say take a
database value and ask it for its
history
which will now make every
uh attribute that it ever had available
to query and so if i issue a query
against this what am i going to get
fred and freddie
and x by the same key that's beautiful
yeah see fred freddy is uh four one
eight and then four and eight again here
but it doesn't include any time it just
gives you all about oh that would be
good if you could get the time
there's not a plane
so
what if we what if we change we're going
to make a new chore right now we've been
reusing the same query over and over
this is the same thing we're going to
make a new character say find email so
this pattern matching that occurs here
basically binds to the datum right ends
the attribute value and time if you
leave something out you just didn't bind
it but if you put something there you
can bind it so we can capture the
transaction values associated with these
datums by just putting another
variable in this binding form so it's
exactly like it was before we added this
tx we'll call this t query
so now if we issue t query against the
database we should get the tx's for
those
there we go there's a tx there
but what happened
how many things do i have now
one of them four
this is effectively across all values of
difference why do i have more now i just
asked to get the tx and now i have more
so
yeah but why would i see how do i see it
fred twice fred at 313 and fred at 3 17.
they're different
retraction
i better have retracted the other one or
i'm going to have two all the time fred
will have two
well
it ends up with this triple and quad
thing it's all a lie they're twins
there's an entity
there's an attribute there's a value
there's a transaction and then there's
whether or not it was an assertion or a
retraction
that's really what's in the datum
it's like a truck has got anything else
so we now have full query which gets all
of those pieces and if we issue full
query across the history we'll see that
this 313 is when we asserted that fred's
email address was fred and 317
is when we retracted that fred's email
was fred so you keep track of all the
transactions
we keep track of everything everywhere
that's good but just the novelty just
the just the just the change right just
the change so this is all small if fred
had a 100 other attributes this would
still be this small it's just like so
sweet
yeah
which we all understand it's like that
get thing yeah
we have something called excise for
forgetting
and that is
that is permanent although it has this
interesting attribute which is that um
while you can forget something
you cannot forget that you forgot it
and we will not we will not let you do
that
without without a record that that
happened
so
you won't know what you knew but you you
will know that you did know something
and you chose not to know it anymore
so that it's auditable
um
cardinality one right if there's
cardinality many many then you could
have like two favorite foods
right so favorite food could have more
than one value at a time
yeah can you chase those excisions up uh
hierarchy can you forget that you forgot
that you forgot it and then you cannot
forget forgetting
even if that's a fact you can't exercise
it no you can't you can't
because i won't let you
because because otherwise the first
promise isn't meaningful
because because you really don't know a
lot about what you exercise you know
sort of the category depending on how
you exercise so if you could say you
could exercise
the value of its exercise
i mean
nothing is kept a new fact is added that
you did it and and what does that fact
know yeah it depends on how you express
it it remembers how you express the
excision okay so you could say exercise
before this period of time this
attribute and you would know that that
happened
but now it's the values obviously if you
kept the values
so really the equipments are all lie too
there's also there's also a sixth thing
that says no no no no no excision it's
actually gone it's off of storage no but
the the records of excisions are
themselves
well they're they're no they're they're
all they're their own facts i just don't
let you exercise them right oh
uh fake
exclusions into the database then um
you might be able to i'm gonna stop that
tomorrow
it's your it's your own problem if
you're saying that i mean yeah yeah
your auditor comes in
no no
this isn't highly encouraged right all
right
so um
we saw that
uh the last thing
i want to show yeah a couple a couple
more things let me just get through this
because i am running out of time
is
this notion of a basis so you can given
any database get a readable
relatively readable
um
value for what the monotonic
incrementing number is for that so we
saw transaction ids before they're big
entity ids because transactions are
entities also but there is this
monotonic time which is encoded inside
that number and you can grab that out
just
basis t
so
and you can also go back and forth
between these two things so given a
monotonic time you can get to
transaction id given a transaction id
you can get the monotonic time
they're mechanical transformations
so what's neat is that if you can
capture a basis thing you can now use
that with these two other functions
which allow you to see the database as
of a certain point in time and you could
you could also put calendar time in
there if you wanted
but you can use these monotonic things
to be extremely precise
and and and get as of incense so we're
going to take the latest db remember
that's after we did everything
and we can say let me see that database
as of
um
the point in time that we did the fred
transaction and what should we see now
remember we're passing the latest
database but we're seeing as of
this point in time after prep what are
we going to see
just fred this is from right after fred
the spaces from from the fred db and we
can also see synths what should we see
in this
freddie and ethan we're not we're not
doing the history chord we're using the
red the first quarry so we're just going
to see
currentness so we can see what happens
so you can do the slicing deck see see a
window of time in the past see slice you
can combine these two things and get a
particular slice so history represents
all the assets and tracks whereas the
history is all the assertions and
retractions as of just says
don't look beyond this point in time
just restrict yourself to this ring of
the tree but it's the same it's the same
the most recent as of that point in time
is what you'll see in the quarry which
is what people ordinarily want to see uh
history core is pretty specific but one
thing that they're saying are you seeing
anything that's been asserted but not
retracted
that's correct
the most recent assertions yeah there's
another way that are different from what
that has up
yes
right
okay so i talked about querying 2db so
let's write a query that takes two
databases we add a new clause here which
is in um in the absence of the in clause
it's a presumption that q is going to
take one argument which would be the
database so instead of having an ambient
database we have a default argument
but when you want to have more than one
database you just start naming them you
say in these two databases i'm going to
call it dollar sign d1 and dollar sign
d2 and then
another line there's something else on
the left hand side of the pattern match
which i left out
which you don't normally need to use
but when you're specifying databases
it's actually the most precise way to
talk about a data is in this database
this entity this attribute this value
this transaction
this assertion or retraction that's
what's completely available to you it's
just the leftmost argument is
not provided when you don't have more
than one thing to distinguish because it
would just be ugly
but when you need to distinguish you
need to distinguish so that's how you do
it so we're going to say
get me the emails from database one and
get emails from database 2 and we're
going to find
we're using the same uh
the same
variable here which is effectively the
way you do joins right it's like logic
variables right use the same variable
and it needs to it needs to bind in both
clauses for both sets and that's how you
do a joint there's no joining logic or
anything else you rename the variable so
this is effectively a query that says
who has the same email address in these
two databases
right but what are the databases well
they're arguments right
this is just a query form
that gets
databases past those arguments so what
databases do we want to pass well let's
pass these two let's let's issue this
new query too saying who had the same
email address in the ethyl database and
in the very latest database
ethel only ethel
fred's email address changed between so
fred doesn't have the same email address
i don't know in most databases this is a
much more tricky quarter
and the other thing i said before is
that uh data is as good as a database
so i've been issuing queries against
databases but when you want to do
testing or you want to ask questions of
your stuff in memory remember one of the
premises on my first slide was bringing
declarative programming to
programs
well that's really true and it was only
limited to the atomic databases well
that wouldn't be a good lie right these
other lines have been good it's like oh
look there's more but that would be a
bad lab it's like oh no that stocks
and it ends up it's not right this
quarry engine it runs against ordinary
data structures
doesn't actually
i mean it has some optimizations when it
encounters these database values
but the logic of that pattern matching
query that applies to any kind of
rectangular
collection so let's pass two collections
to query two this is the query that said
who had the same email address in these
two databases
let's see but now instead of passing two
this is the same query
query two this is the same function q
this is not databases from the database
this is a vector
of a vector with the tuple of
symbols and
keywords and strings and another vector
this is not mocking anymore
this is programming with values because
i told you right if you have a program
if you have programs that lets you make
values you can use it and so you do so
we're going to issue the query against
this and what's it going to say
lucy
all right well that's all i had time to
show tonight
uh any quick questions i can take five
more minutes of questions
is there someone we can play with this
yes go to daytona.com in fact we just uh
last week announced that
a starter version that lets you use all
of the storages
so two peers in all of the storages you
can try it out against dynamo or sql or
anything you want and that's
it's free and
is a it's a
perpetual license so
you can really try it you can build
product small production systems that
way
um
no charge so
what's left
what's not free
a version that allows you to have an
arbitrary number of peers so that
version will let you have two peers or
two application servers we
you know the ones we sell will let you
have
more
the other things that's missing is it
does not have the ability to use
memcache which is a transparent aspect
of data you basically say you can buy
memcache and we'll put we'll use it as
an internal cache it does not have that
it does not have
it does not have high availability let's
do it that's the other thing
so the
full version of the atomic you can start
up two transactors and one will wait for
the other one to have a problem and
immediately take over
and it doesn't have that
so that's it otherwise that's everything
else including you know quite language
all the storage back-ends you can run
there's a memory database that you can
run so referring testing you know you
can have to use the storage you can do
all the stuff in memory
with a version that keeps database and
memory
so this is not a question but a comment
this is very similar to what we're doing
at bank of america
with you know michael naughton he came
from goldman
i think everybody's going to end up here
i mean it's just there's so much
business pressure to
not forget things to have auditability
to understand time people want to do
more analysis they need to know
your knowledge at some point in time
what was your view yeah and just to see
things over time you know for instance
if you have a let's say it's very
typical thing let's say you have a your
you make products and you have suppliers
of parts for the product and you keep
that in a database with the like the
part and the price in a place-oriented
database every time your supplier
changes the price you nuke the price
before then somebody comes up to your
business person comes up and says does
it seem like
you know this supplier always changes
their prices in june
should we be buying may in may from them
to like
and you're like
i wish i could help you there all i know
to find out your historical profit
anything this is just important this is
how we think
how many people could make good
decisions if you didn't remember before
yesterday
you couldn't
you couldn't and that's what we're
asking businesses to do but we don't do
that we use git
right we log everything in our programs
we're like crazy man i don't want to
have to debug this program without a log
of like every possible thing it did
i don't want to be in that position by
my business owner though you know
that's using
so when you have um with the persistent
maps and vectors you can have like a
vector
slightly similar vectors and that's
something that comes up when you're
trying to model by temporality which is
a concept of time changing in time like
a series of time series
uh
so like let's say you have like a
million vectors that are all slightly
similar or slightly different and
there's a lot of shared structure that
fit that thing in memory enclosure very
easily between the persistent
if you if you built it against atomic in
the same way you would build it in
memory which is the sharing was visible
to you as you built it
you can get the same kind of sharing if
you think that sharing is going to
magically occur it will only magically
occur if you used identities
consistently
okay does that make sense yeah all right
you can pretty much just
get it as of your physical
knowledge time on the database and then
cut off whatever is your business
i'm going to take one more question but
i want to thank everybody for coming
this is what i use